la colère monte chez les salariés Renaud
de Flin ce mardi matin ils ont effectué
leur première opération coup de point
aux abords du site bloquant la
circulation pendant près d'une heure
leur message est clair ils vont se
battre contre le plan de compétitivité
annoncé par la direction qui prévoit
entre 7500 et 8260 suppressions d'emploi
dont plus de la moitié en départ naturel
aujourd'hui c'est un avertissement
demain vous verrez on on est capable on
est déterminé on est capable de se
battre comme des lions pour empêcher le
chômage de ravager la vie de millions de
gens pendant que les autres s'en mettent
plein les poches on est capable d'aller
très très très loin personne ne le
soupçonne on est déterminé selon les
syndicats la marcoosange aurait réalisé
un profit de 786 millions d'euros sur
les 6 premiers mois de 2012 pour la
première fois depuis l'annonce du plan
les agents de maîtrise se serent joint
au mouvement cette révolte s'adresse
aussi au gouvernement on voudrait faire
passer ce message à monbourg parce que
monbourg effectivement on a vu qu'
chantait à l'émission mais nous pour
nous monbour c'est parolle et paroles
les paroles il a des très belles paroles
mais bon il a quand même 15 % en Renault
et l'État ont 15 % et on pense que de
paroles il faut qu'il passe au actes les
salariés étaient près de 500 ce matin
réunis devant l'usine Renaud de fin et
les syndicats donnent déjà rendez-vous
mardi prochain 5 février pour une
nouvelle
action